Ratchet and Clank is the new film
adaptation of a game that's out right
now
that's a game adaptation of a film
that's coming out that's also a film
adaptation of the game however you want
to look at that this movies in theaters
yay now I'm not a huge Ratchet and Clank
fan but I have played some of the games
I do have the new ps4 game and it is a
lot of fun it's a good game my friends
however growing up loved Ratchet and
Clank and we talked about it all the
time so I do have some knowledge of the
games they're basically just really fun
space adventures so ratchet is a
mechanic and he has big dreams of space
adventure he wants to go out and save
the universe eventually he meets Clank
and they team up to save the universe
from this evil guy who wants to blow
everything up and he's evil and this
movies not as good as the games it is
however incredibly harmless there really
is nothing to be upset about here the
movie makes a lot of references to other
films there's posters that look like
Conan there's posters that look like
Ferris Bueller's Day Off there's a guy
that falls off of something and he does
the famous
Wilhelm scream and his friend is like
will home there's jokes like that in
this film that are going to reach movie
fans and as a movie fan I appreciated
them there is an effort here to be
clever and to be entertaining some of
the action is fun the animation is not
great it's kind of straight-to-dvd
worthy in fact I kind of feel like this
movie had a better place on perhaps a
Netflix rather than theaters and the
fact that there was myself and two other
people in the theater tonight that may
have been a better choice the
unfortunate truth is despite the fact
that some of the characters are charming
and likable and Ratchet and Clank
themselves have some really fun
interplay and as someone who wasn't huge
into the games but still enjoyed them I
did find some harmless entertainment
with this film but it really is just a
cliched exercise in releasing a film
into theaters to tie it into a game a
much better game and hopefully have that
property make some more money because of
that it's kind of a giant promotional
exercise and somehow they got people
like rosario Dawson Paul Giamatti
on Goodman in the voice cast and the
voice cast is very good but there is an
undeniable sense that I got while
watching this movie and that sense is
paycheck collection this is a film that
some people are probably being paid a
lot of money to make and will hopefully
make more money for the video game and
vice versa and it just sort of feels
like that and it can't really be escaped
despite some of the movie's efforts to
be entertaining and to have some good
sci-fi action the villains and the
heroes are all very stereotypical and
there really isn't that attempt to step
outside the box but if you're a fan of
these games and these characters you
might not require it to step out of the
box it might not bother you you might be
perfectly fine with that and this movie
is really harmless there's nothing about
it that really bugged me it was just
very mediocre and passable I think some
critics are really going to tear into
this movie and from what I looked on
Rotten Tomatoes they are because it's a
video game movie and already some people
just go into this movie ready to hate it
but I went into it excited actually
because I like these characters growing
up I wasn't the big mammoth Ratchet and
Clank fan but I appreciated the games
and I had fun with them and so did my
friends and I walked out thinking you
know it's a movie it probably should
have been on Netflix but there isn't
anything about it that made me angry
it's just aggressively mediocre
unfortunately despite some charming
characters I'm gonna give Ratchet and
Clank a C+ should it have been released
in theaters probably not should have
been straight to DVD or Netflix
nevertheless there really isn't anything
to be upset about here it's not that bad
when compared to other video game
adaptations that's for sure guys thank
you so much as always for watching if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes